well I mean he fought his way to be the
king my lord give him one more honor so
Oscar nominees are out not something I
would usually talk about because
honestly the only reason I paid to the
Oscars at all is because I'm in an Oscar
pool and the party that that the people
in the pool get to go to also has really
good food if it wasn't for that I
probably wouldn't pay attention to the
Oscars at all anymore but I do and black
panther got nominated for Best Picture
which is good that's not a bad thing I
think it's a nice acknowledgement on
multiple levels I think it's a it's a
nice acknowledgment of the validity of
blockbuster filmmaking by an entity that
very rarely acknowledges blockbuster
films anymore along with a validity to
what is the biggest genre in film right
now which is superhero films and also
honoring what it was undeniably
regardless of what you think of the film
itself it was undeniably a cultural
touchstone this year yet at the same
time it can't help but feel a bit token
on a lot of fronts so oh boy where do we
start well first off let's let's
backtrack a little bit the Oscars ditch
the the hole oh we're gonna have a most
popular film category concept good
because that was really dumb and I
thought that was gonna really really
bite them in the butt and especially
this year because as I think it was Bob
Shipman pointed out that if they did
make that category black panther would
be the presumed frontrunner and just
imagine how bad it would look if Black
Panther won what was a literal
separate-but-equal Best Picture Oscar
yeah so yeah that was the house good
idea for them to not do it but the
reason I can't get super excited about
this
the way that you know I was able to get
excited like say when the Lord of the
Rings films got all you know each year
all got nominated for a whole bunch of
stuff because that was also a genre that
didn't really get it to do from
Hollywood in that case being fantasy
it was also blockbuster films and you
know the the the reason that this can't
give me that same sense of yeah is that
well I looked at what the categories it
was nominated in were so yes it was not
only for Best Picture which is obviously
the prize that's the big one and it's
got how many nominations total it's got
six which is respectable until you start
looking up specifically what they are or
more specifically at what they aren't
now it's generally not a good sign when
or at least a good sign in terms of the
prospects of it actually winning when a
Best Picture nominee doesn't also have a
corresponding Best Director or Best
Screenplay or Best Actor in any category
actor actress Supporting Actor
Supporting Actress
none of it basically black panther is up
for Best Picture and then from there
it's all just technicals it's score and
it's costume design and it's sound
mixing and it's production design and
the sound editing not even hair and
makeup which should have been a
no-brainer so it is nominated for the
big prize and that a bunch of technicals
like it's not gonna win there's
absolutely no chance that is going to
win I I would have hoped there would
have been an outside chance for a
nomination for Michael B Jordan in the
Supporting Actor category that didn't
happen I wasn't really expecting Ryan
Coogler to get a Best Director
nomination but overall I just can't help
but look at that go you know this is one
of those years that you guys are really
grateful that you expanded the
list of nominees for Best Picture - up
to ten isn't it because this is this is
just the kind of move where they're
putting it there to look and buy better
I don't mean that like the other films
nominated aren't worth it or that they
aren't good or that the Academy has no
idea what it's like now what I just mean
the Academy I mean Hollywood in general
but the Academy specifically has at this
point a long-running reputation for
being very out of touch and this I mean
this has the same feel of like avatar
getting nominated it's like see we like
big popular movies - yeah but it's not
coming in so who who cares I mean that
said it is if if they were going to
nominate some what token Lee a
blockbuster superhero film I think this
was the one to go with that's not even
necessary because I think it's the best
superhero film that came out this year I
actually don't think it is what if you
go back and look at my top 10 movies of
2018 there were two superhero movies
well Act no three but one of them was a
direct-to-dvd so that wouldn't have been
up for it anyway but - Oscar qualifying
superhero released movies that I ranked
above black panther so I don't even
think it was the best film but I do
think that if you were gonna numb anyone
that's the one to go with because the
thing to remember about the Oscars is
that as much as they may use terms like
Best Picture Best Actor this is a this
show and these awards are by their
nature a combination self-congratulatory
party and sort of political sideshow and
by political I don't necessarily mean
Washington politics and politics like
Democratic Republic
politics I mean Hollywood politics this
is the chance for you know the people
who live in these friggin mansions and
are responsible for a ton of money try
and look appealing I mean because I'm a
big part of the point of the Oscars is
to sell the mythology of Hollywood and
if that mythology of Hollywood isn't
appealing to your average moviegoer at
all then it's failing so part of the way
you get to appeal is by nominating
movies people have actually seen which
of course as I've said almost never win
but it does seem to show a certain
recognition of of the importance and
especially like if you're gone and a son
nominates something that was never gonna
win you might as well have that
nomination have some some meaning in and
of itself and I do think there is some
meaning to be had by nominating a movie
like Black Panther for if if only in
acknowledgement of its cultural
relevance and as a touchstone for the
moment in time when it came out and what
it meant to a great deal of people I do
think there is a certain amount of
validity in doing that given the fact
that it's not gonna win and it was never
gonna win you know if it's a if it's a
gonna be a throw away nomination anyway
this is still a way to grant it some
vague degree of relevance but but yeah
it's not gonna win as far as other Oscar
nominees that are up go I don't really
have too much to say I don't I have seen
almost none of the other major nominees
like I can't even remember I haven't
seen black Klansmen I haven't seen
Bohemian Rhapsody I haven't seen the
favorite Green Book Roma stars for
advice like Black Panthers the only Best
Picture nominee I've seen Supporting
Actress Beale Street favorite I oh god I
haven't seen any of these I haven't seen
any of the movies that the Best
Supporting Actor or Best Supporting
Actress categories are nominated in I
haven't seen any of the films that
the best actor and Best Actress nominees
are in I haven't seen any of the movies
that director are nominated for like I
haven't seen any of these so like I have
basically nothing to say about these
other nominees because they're the
pretty standard end-of-year art you know
but still kind of safe for the most part
sort of films that generally get
nominated and tend to win it's it's a
pretty boring lineup and you know with
black panther trying desperately to add
a little bit of spice to the proceedings
and again it's not that that there's no
value in it but it's it's pretty
superficial
at the end of the day so black panther
up for Best Picture
did I just completely put a damper on
people being excited about this I don't
know I'm sure I'll find out the comments
what are your thoughts about it whatever
they are drops let me know in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff to do there's a buttons and
there's links and there's things to
check out go check them out down below
use a link to my patreon if you want to
for me that way there is peel box all
sorts of stuff but if you don't want to
look at any of it that is okay so at the
end of the day you are the council and I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]